my name is a clue sash I go to school in
the coastal town of Grand papo & Baneen
you see the lesson I'm in my sixth year
there there are 36 students in my class
I'll take my exams and a year I want to
qualify for university and study
journalism poor fella finale I like
modern music
suruga on the road that links cotonou
the capital of benin to togo you see the
heart these are the oranges that my aunt
cells to customers at her refreshment
stand suppose it up I see yeah I'm oh no
my uncle works as a mechanic this is his
workshop very repairs motorcycles who
utilize until the new body soluto asked
me Mommy this is my mother she's a
housewife and Grandpa pool her name is
acolo ta appellee it is out that
differences my father his name is a clue
Danielle he's a driver and Grandpa PO he
gets up early in the morning and I don't
get to see him every day he's strict
with us so that will do well in school
and we can make something of ourselves
oh goodness I'll and um do me
love it to wash I go to the well let's
lower a bucket into it and then I can
shop lovey
see some hot applies we're on the beach
here yeah there are flowers everywhere
but also litter that pollutes the
environment in the sea the plastic waste
products get washed out to sea and kill
the turtles the turtles mistake them for
food they talk to local phone yeah I
don't know what you
16 years since the start of the
millennium 16 years of life global is
visiting young people around the world
who were born in the year 2000 whoa I
love dancing for look what's important
to our gel from the seychelles and what
does seem on love about life in Buenos
Aires join us on our series millennium
teens you'll find all the details online